on today's show two up-and-coming actors
who really have a chance to break
through in hollywood
we're not available so instead we
decided to have a raucous rumble of
royalty who probably owns rolls royces
tom hanks versus denzel washington more
realistic than batman v
superman more or less named diversity
than kramer vs kramer
this is the battle we've wanted to see
break out in the front row of the oscars
for four decades now
it's america's dad taking on america's
thespian two of the most acclaimed
celebrated and beloved performers in the
history of telling stories
neither is just an ordinary john q but
only one will get the victory and truly
be
in a league of their own who writes this
garbage oh right
okay hmm here's how we'll determine a
winner
round one box office round two tomato
meter slash audience score
round three characters and then we'll do
a wild card round that usually helps
settle the score
but in this case it could just make the
outcome murkier and then the idiot
writer of this show will have to
determine a winner
and to be clear the writer right why are
you smiling
let's get it on king kong ain't got [ __ ]
on me houston we have a problem round
one
box office times change people change
hairstyles change but regardless of
constantly shifting cinematic trends
the two constants in hollywood for over
40 years have been denzel washington
and tom hanks putting butts in seats
it's my job
it's my responsibility comedy action
romance horror sci-fi drama they have
every section at blockbuster covered
including new releases but before they
land on home video or laserdisc
hanks and washington movies make quite a
stir at the box office
both stars had big breaks in tv early on
in their career
and it was washington's run on saint
elsewhere that made him
a household name but once he left onto
the big screen with 1990s glory
he'd become one of the most sought after
leads in hollywood history
his movies have amassed a domestic total
of 3.92 billion dollars making for a per
film average
of 85 million and while remember the
titans crimson tide and the endlessly
rewatchable american gangster
all help pad those stats
it's the pelican brief that gave him his
biggest hit with a 214 million dollar
total in receipts that's the first but
not last
julia roberts movie i'll mention in
today's virtual essay
come on she's america's sweetheart so
you know
follow me
oh and she's also worked with tom hanks
in charlie wilson's war
and larry crown and while i'm sure moped
gangs lined up around the block to see
larry's sweet ride
those two movies combined wouldn't make
it onto the top 10 of one of the most
profitable careers
in talking picture history tom hanks
movies have raked in a total of 8.48
billion in domestic bucks
which gives him a per film average of
173 million
and if you're crying about a snake in
your boot let's see how mr
s pumpkins does without those four
behemoth toy story movies no no no
no no no 6.7 billion dollars would be
the total
with an average of 149 million is that
good enough for you
and while denzel has two flicks that
piled over 200 million dollars in cash
tom has five movies that have each done
at least
300 million including apollo 13
which i'm told is based on a true story
saving private ryan which felt like a
true story and castaway which i want to
be my life story
ah just me and a volleyball and blazing
fires and
performing dental experiments
[Music]
tom hanks all-time highest grossing
movie is of course
forrest gump whose adventures made for a
703
million dollar total that buys a lot of
shrimp
bubblegum shrimp it's a household name
but before i just hand this round over
to josh baskin i would like to note that
denzel
had the higher degree of difficulty as
over half of his movies are rated r
yeah you're going to need your parents
permission to see 62 percent of his
films oh [ __ ]
while less than a quarter of hanks's
movies feature that rating
violence yes nudity yes adult situations
okay still not sure what that means i
especially like that move in the fifth
inning when you
scratched your balls for an hour
anything worth doing is worth doing
right
and as i've had to say so often about my
beloved nfl team
washington puts up a fight but
ultimately comes up
short tom hanks gets the box office nod
and wins round number one
for a one-to-nothing lead you're right
round two tomato leader slash audience
score
let's be honest any one of us would pay
money to see denzel and tom do
just about anything that includes
collecting bones
battling volcanoes or riding mopeds i'm
gonna do
one of those jokes per round so get used
to it
but which star has a better track record
when it comes to audiences
leaving the theater no we're talking
about you leave and then you talk about
it with critics or
your fellow audience members the tomato
meter or
audience score it's going to be a fresh
conversation i'm willing to bet
because both of these guys have earned
career fresh averages
on both metrics over a course of a
combined 96
films tom hanks has the slight edge in
tomato meter average with 68 percent
to denzel washington's 66
but mr shuttlesworth answers from way
downtown with a 70 percent audience
score average
to hank's 66 percent it's gonna be a
close race
so before we dive deep into each actor's
top ten let's remind ourselves that even
all-time greats
can make a few questionable decisions
for tom hanks it made sense to star in a
series of big time movies based
on dan brown's da vinci code novel
series
it just didn't play out all that well in
the eyes of critics
the robert langdon trilogy averages just
28
on the tomato meter and i gotta think
most of that was based on the haircut
you ever tell you look like a penis with
a little hat on so let's stay rotten
with denzel
whose highlights on the wrong side of
fresh include the book of eli
what i like that movie and man on fire
what that movie slaps
don't worry m on f does have an 88
audience score it's more like it as far
as the best of the best go
tom hanks would run away with this
category if we count the toy story
movies the first two are literally
at a hundred percent on the tomato meter
but even if we strike buzz
woody and forkey from the record it's
tom hanks who still boasts
eight of the combined top ten movies for
every glory or fences there's a big
catch me if you can or that thing you do
right alongside it
it's very important you don't stink
today hey i make no guarantees
but while the top 10 is important and
that pixar run has been nothing short of
astounding
maybe it's a testament to denzel
washington's ability that his more
character driven films
can compete with the crowd pleasers that
hanks is best known for
romantic comedies and animated flicks
are great
yet washington still has the slight
advantage over hanks in terms of
audience score
since i walk in both the tomato meter
and audience score worlds
around here they they call me the blade
of rotten tomatoes
no one's ever called me that i'm gonna
have to side with the measurement that
gave man on fire it's due
and in doing so giving denzel washington
the win in round number two
it's all tied up at one a piece this
isn't falling with style
this is fine either you're somebody
or you're nobody round three characters
malcolm forest alonzo sully
yes those are my drinking buddies but
they're also just a sample of the
characters you know by first name alone
and that's in large part because of how
well denzel washington and tom hanks
played the roles
there's nothing these dudes can't pull
off fantastical fictional heroes
real life people fake people in real
events
tom and denzel do it all each actor has
two oscars above one of their many
fireplaces
denzel struck first earning his best
supporting actor statue as private trip
in glory
it's a transcendental performance that
showed us the reaches
and depths that washington could go to i
ain't fighting this war
and it was denzel that supported tom
hanks getting his first little gold guy
in philadelphia and while hanks is note
perfect
denzel is just as great with all due
respect your honor
we don't live in this courtroom though
do we hanks would go on to pull on the
ultra
rare back to back winning an oscar the
very next year
for greenbow alabama jogging enthusiast
forrest gump
my mom always said life was like
a box of chocolates denzel would match
tom's oscar total when he won again in
2000 for alonso in training day
in office baby
going up hanks has also received a claim
for roles as diverse as
man trial josh baskin and big and fedex
weight fluctuator chuck noland in
castaway
it's astounding how much range tom is
able to display
while being so likable in virtually
every film he's in we'll buy him as a
charming romantic lead opposite meg ryan
and sleepless in seattle
or you've got mail or the volcano movie
but then will also root for him just as
hard in
harrowing thrillers like captain
phillips and saving private ryan
when's the last time you feel good about
anything go watch bridge of spies from
2015
then remind yourself that tom hanks
began his career as a fun comedy guy
he graduated from the sitcom bosom
buddies to comedy hits like bachelor
party
splash and the money pit oh and fun fact
he co-starred with sally field
in the classic ish stand-up comedy movie
punchline to prep for the role he pouted
around new york city comedy clubs and
started doing sets
impressing young comics like chris rock
so much
they swore he could have made a very
successful career on stage
so on behalf of all other comedians tom
babe thanks for sticking with acting
the rest of us need all the work we can
get wonder woman
wonder woman flew an invisible jet
how did she find it denzel washington
may not have the breadth of genre that
hanks does
but he more than makes up for it with
some of the most powerful turns in
cinematic history
two oscar wins is great but just
consider how many more awards he easily
could have garnered
his 1992 portrayal of malcolm x is
nothing short of jaw-dropping
[Music]
go ahead and keep those jaws on the
floor when i tell you that he lost the
academy award that year
to captain hoo no one's ever gonna say
al pacino isn't a first ballot hall of
famer
but come on no i don't think i will
maybe i could give that snub a pass
if denzel wasn't also jobbed as reuben
hurricane
carter in and out of the ring that may
have been washington's best performance
ever i serve my time in a house of
justice and yet there's no justice for
me
denzel's characters can be loved or
feared but always respected
whether he's coach herman boone in the
inspiring remember the titans
or drug kingpin frank lucas an american
gangster
he commands your attention at all times
and sometimes
washington is so good we the audience
aren't sure whether to root for him or
not
hence his oscar for training day so you
entertain me with your [ __ ]
but it's tom hanks who can light it up
with so many different styles
and thus i feel his characterography
i invented a word see that can we patent
that
make some um hanks denzel money is a bit
more diverse
plus he went full eddie murphy and
played like six people in cloud atlas
sure one of them sounded a bit too much
like jar jar binks but hey
that's brett's baby misa gives tom hanks
the
round and he's up 2-1
gentlemen
it's been a privilege flying with you
and now it's time for the wild card
round
iconic moments when your acting career
is defined by boffo box office
memorable characters and you have a
summer home on the fresh side of the
tomato meter
chances are you've given us some iconic
moments over the years
for denzel and tom these instances run
the gamut from just a tiny look to a
climactic award show friendly monologue
tom hanks certainly isn't the only star
in penny marshall's classic sports film
a league of their own but he still
manages to showcase
his wide range of ability he can knock a
line like there's no crying
there's no crying in baseball out of the
park
then make us how with laughter when
nature calls
extensively in the locker room
but for me the shining moment in that
film is opposite gina davis when he
reminds her
just how special and yes difficult
baseball is
if it wasn't hard everyone would do it
the hard is what makes it great
washington can also inspire the masses
as few folks on earth could have pulled
off the complexity of emotion embodied
by coach herman boone he's at times
affable and charming and within the same
scene
barely containing frustration boiling
underneath the surface
but there's never a doubt as to who's in
charge
there's also no doubt that i'm running
10 miles after watching his speech
delivered to the high school football
team
at gettysburg
take a lesson from the dead
if we don't come together
right now on this hollow ground
we too will be destroyed and whereas tom
hanks can jump from the dramatic to the
comedic with ease
denzel can give us a strong leader
that's a hero or a villain
just ask bumpy how strong-arming frank
lucas went for him
the breakfast diner scene in american
gangster was the setting for a
two-minute master class
on how to exemplify everything about a
character imagine going back to eating
pancakes at that table
so what was i saying the thing that
impresses me most about tom hanks
is the links he'll go to to give us a
moment as an audience
even at the expense of his own health he
often gained a ton of weight to make us
believe he was a castaway
and it paid off for audiences as soon as
we see that makeshift spear hit the fish
and then the new slim four years on an
island chuck reveals himself
and speaking of links one is willing to
go forrest gump
ran all over the globe then jogged
america
all for our entertainment and josh
baskin gave us perhaps the most fun
piano duet in movie history
be honest every time you see a big piano
you want to do it
[Music]
for denzel washington it's his duet with
on-screen counterparts that have
cemented his legacy
it's dazzling to watch him slowly reveal
who he is to ethan hawk's unwitting cop
in training day
and if you think the king kong speech is
brilliant check out what he does
as malcolm x the slave mayan soliloquy
is just as resonant today
almost 30 years after spike lee's joint
was released in theaters
and just because you can usually find it
on one of ted turner's channels on a
saturday afternoon
check out crimson tide again gene
hackman going toe-to-toe with denzel
washington just another example of how
tony scott spoiled us audiences time and
time again
thank you tony you can't go wrong with
either actor to win this round but i'm
leaning
slightly towards the guy whose iconic
moments tend to be more
singular and powerful and yes memorable
and make me work out more i'm sorry
woody
turner and sully denzel wins this round
we're tied and now we need to move on
before i get emotional thinking about
that captain phillips
medical attention scene my god
who's your daddy guy who's your daddy
you all right folks here we are it
doesn't take a genius like roman j
israel esquire to predict we could end
in a tie and that the decision to
declare a winner would fall into my
barely capable elf hands here we are
hanks versus washington same amount of
oscars it's a virtual dead heat
according to critics and audiences
so the only way to determine a winner is
stall for time not only are tom and
denzel accomplished actors directors and
producers
they're each responsible for ushering in
new generations of greatness
thanks to their generosity charlize
theron has attributed her entire career
to tom hanks
taking a chance on her when she was an
unknown giving her a role in that thing
you do
and chadwick boseman was able to attend
a summer intensive at oxford
thanks to a scholarship paid for by
denzel washington
we audiences love these two men so many
current performers
are forever in their debt so now back to
me and let's take a look at them oscar
wins a little more closely
each of their combined four wins was
richly deserved no doubt about it
but as the academy sometimes might give
a award as a makeup call for a
previously questionable decision
perhaps i can use my platform to
similarly
right a wrong tomax has earned his place
atop mount a-list by making us laugh cry
and think with such a natural touch and
while he possibly could have won another
oscar for
castaway or captain phillips it's the
intensity focus
and searing honesty we get from denzel
that in my opinion
has gone overlooked too often in no
world should hua have defeated malcolm x
and i could also argue that the
hurricane
and flight should have earned him more
statues as anyone who's ever stared at a
hotel minibar will tell you
that scene in flight resonates hard
so in what will go down in history as
just as valuable as an academy award
i mark ellis hereby declare denzel
washington the winner in today's
gut-wrenching episode of verses
make it rain
and no this isn't because of how turner
and hooch ended but that certainly
didn't help
tom look hanks is gonna be okay he's out
there dating mermaids
flirting online making mopeds just a tad
bit cooler
and if i have to be on someone's bad
side i'd rather be mr rogers than john
creasy
but hey that's just my opinion now we
turn it over to you
the world at large comment below and let
us know which actor do you prefer what's
your favorite movie of either their
catalogs
thanks for watching everyone make sure
you hit that like button click that
notification bell
and remember this was a very tough
decision for me but
as a great hitter once said the hard is
what makes it great
i'm mark ellis reminding you never wear
a fur coat to a prize fight
you